it's not just these random weirdos who
throw Hissy Fits at fast food
restaurants this is even prominent
people who are behaving in a way that is
hysterical in the face of reality
there's an actor Billy Porter I'm not
sure that I've ever seen him in anything
but I do see him pop up on talk shows
and in commercials and things like that
Billy Porter was just on The View
whining and screaming and carrying on
about Ron DeSantis
is about power and you could always
it's very hypocritical you know the the
leading cause of death in children are
guns yeah yeah they're guns yeah I know
it's the morning and I'm not supposed to
be screaming but they're guns yeah
not drag queen no leave us alone
you know and
it's a distraction it's a distraction on
purpose
here he goes on and and he just says a
lot of things that
sound like they're an argument but
they're not which Libs do a lot they're
these kind of non-sectors and it's
hypocrisy and there are distractions and
you want to talk about let's talk about
let's talk about corporate taxes okay
let's talk about the Second Amendment
all right let's talk about the the 12th
Amendment okay and you just think well
what are we what are you saying about
any of those things nothing really guns
I can't even do it I can't even do the
Billy Porter impression what is he
talking about with guns he's saying the
big threat to Children is guns not drag
queens no one's saying that drag queens
are murdering children we're saying that
drag queens are scandalizing children in
drag queen's Story Hour is bringing
often uh sexual criminals child
molesters into places like libraries and
schools to jiggle around in sexualized
costumes for children and that's
obviously depraved and wrong and in some
cases already is illegal and in other
cases should be illegal and we should
stop it
well what about the guns what are you
saying about that that's a completely
separate issue
and it's true that guns are the leading
cause of death among children it's very
close it's just slightly ahead of
automobile accidents so are you
suggesting that we ban automobiles too
what's your is your argument that we ban
guns and we take away the Second
Amendment we rewrite the Constitution
and we deny people's right to defend
themselves is that is that what you're
what are you saying you're not saying
any of that you're not making any kind
of argument at all you're trying to
distract and you're distracting by
yelling and screaming and wailing and
carrying on and as a rule of thumb if
your ideology causes you to wail and
scream first thing in the morning is
Billy Porter acknowledges
there is probably something wrong
with your ideology
I notice this every time I go visit
different schools
I'm going to be going to Purdue this
week
we're in that in a second but
I was just at the University of Buffalo
and the protesters come out and they
whale and they scream and they carry on
occasionally I'm able to speak to them
we actually have pretty pretty
interesting interview with with some of
the protesters at Buffalo coming out
soon stay tuned for that but when you
speak to them one-on-one and you just
try to get them to re be reasonable and
you say hey okay here's here's your
premise here's the logical conclusion of
that here's why your premise is wrong
here's my premise here's the conclusion
of that here's why that would that's
correct and more appealing and more
conducive to human flourishing
they can calm down but then sometimes
they just they go right back to it and
they start wailing and they start
screaming that's a good if you find
yourself falling down that rabbit hole
recognize there's something wrong the
people who are correct
the people who are confident in their
views don't need to wail and scream
sometimes cooler heads prevail before we
go we weren't able to to get to too much
on this today though there's not a ton
of breaking news on it we're waiting to
see if the Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg
indicts Donald Trump arrests el el
Donaldo and Trump seems to be leaning
into this
might be the best thing that could
happen to his campaign and it shows you
just how obscenely corrupt the political
system is in the United States that the
libs would now try to arrest the leader
of the political opposition the chief
rival to the current President Van Jones
who is a Democrat he's a lib he's on CNN
he is imploring his fellow Democrats
he's imploring the D.A he's saying hey
let's let cooler heads prevail and not
cross the Rubicon here my view about
this is uh I think that the heat is on
this D.A I think he's going to make a
very sober decision and I would not be
surprised if he doesn't step back from
the brain
this is so is this van Jones's
prediction or is this van Jones's
advocacy
saying yo brag calm down here man this
is this is going to be an escalation of
the political war in this country that
we have we have never seen anything like
this a former president and current top
presidential candidate being arrested
for what because of totally trumped up
charges
now the libs are very angry with Van
Jones but he's obviously right hard to
go back from that because if they do
arrest Trump one it might help Trump
Trump's campaign but two the Republicans
who are in these positions of authority
DA's Attorneys General and governors to
bring political pressure
should arrest five of their guys
not innocent people but criminal Libs
there's no shortage of criminal Libs out
there who are not being held to account
by the law
if they arrest our guy we need to arrest
five of their guys
okay and we'll see and we'll see who's
laughing by the end of that exercise
okay if the conservatives can muster the
spine I think they might be able to
conservatives have mustered a lot more
of a spine in recent years
then we can't just roll over and allow
the libs to arrest the political
opposition and turn us into a complete
Banana Republic so then we have to
arrest their guys and it escalates and
it escalates and escalates and is that
where the libs want to take the
political order
maybe they're willing to take the BET
maybe they're willing to play that game
of chicken but that's a dangerous game
of chicken says van Jones and he says
back off I'm going to Purdue I guess I'm
going to Purdue tomorrow I better finish
writing my speech I have not finished
writing my speech yet and already
multiple
protests are scheduled to try to start
my visit
according to the Purdue exponent two
different protests have been planned
against May one will take place
at the same Ballroom that I will be
speaking in my critics are so confused
that they can't even agree on how to
protest me
and the posters the ones that I've seen
at least say that I'm a fascist they put
all sorts of swastikas on me they say no
fascists allowed on campus
yeah
you know a week ago I learned that I was
a genocidal Maniac I had never
considered myself much of a genocide man
but that's what I learned by reading the
newspapers now I learn I'm a fascist
again had not really considered myself a
fascist but maybe I'll have to go back
to some of those fascist writings try to
request but I'm pretty sure I'm not a
fascist
but that's what they say they just
escalate it up and up and up it does go
along with my new nickname Benito
michalini uh but they'll do anything
they'll do anything to prevent me from
speaking and why why is that
it's because two weeks ago I said that
men can't really be women and we should
stop pretending that they can and we
should stop indulging this Preposterous
ideology in public life at every level
and they lost it and they were so they
were so convinced they could cancel me
and then when the entire conservative
media from the most squishy to the most
from yeah basically the most squishy I'm
not going to name names but very very
squishy media figures on the right all
the way to the most right wing they
essentially all defended my speech
because it's obviously true men can't
really be women and we can't tolerate
this stuff we really should not tolerate
it then
top Republican politicians multiple U.S
senators they came out and the libs were
so angry
that they weren't able to squash this
idea they were so angry that for the
first time in a very long time
conservatives might not just be playing
defense and trying to slow down the lips
might be trying to reclaim ground that
the libs thought they had already
conquered they were so angry that now
they're calling me Hitler they're going
to try to shut this down they threaten
violence they do all this kind of stuff
okay well it doesn't worry us
we come in prepared you're not going to
intimidate us we'll be there on Thursday
so if you're in the Purdue area come on
by say hey and you can listen to the
speech the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member and use code Knowles
Canada wlas a checkout for two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]